the politicians campert and the jumping
former spartan on trump if it radical
islam i there so that's why he's going for
temporary berman muslim center united
states and double trouble pile of legal
immigration by building wal and there was
a border very mix crawled hey for
mexico be  like what the hell in therefore the
lecture at my work about the get of
like roundup al bisex was a place
them in a large young sweden at number 10
eur pln for sure why do some will also
a real national almost nando's creepy
of apprentice are you  guys are often a car
dealerships that are as peaceful as a
you grow the goal to can sleep at night
pikachu er peaceful masters equally nice
print a table trample cat flap juice
badger de maastunnel it still on you
actually a there
indulgence you guessed mexico just as
well  can't get an engagement and your
mobile exadata short call rate i thought
i check and coat your pair america
could get any better
mr appelboom that all spiders and last
him inte  rface how python do a pilot
still have a place it breaks anymore
how pepper thus camaguey jtg past
mexico
[Applause]
wassenaar degree glass
subscribe to my youtube channel for
one and lessons priref join go go go go go
go